hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game from the 1896 uh
tournament that was played in nuremberg
in germany it was played between emil
shalop and mikhail chigorin uh you guys
pretty much you know who chigrin was a
charlotte on the other hand he was uh he
wasn't an unknown player he was well
known in the chess circles but he was
never really a chess professional uh he
uh often played for fun and he wanted to
have a good time and create something
fun on the board and well that's why
maybe when he played against the
absolute
uh top class uh he didn't do all that
great but if you give him a weaker
opponent he would just obliterate him
and you know uh pieces would just be
flying over the board we're gonna
show at least one such game after this
one but now let's uh concentrate on this
one but it's a very interesting
tournament and it would be fun to cover
pretty much all the games from this
tournament uh all you know uh if if
anything for for uh some sort of a
historical value uh but as i am planning
to make some more sagas in the future we
will probably be covering this
tournament as well so uh we're gonna
return to it at some point so uh shallop
with the white pieces opens with e4 we
have e5 by chigoden knight to f3 knight
to c6 and the bishop to b5 uh shalt goes
for the royal lopez we have a6 morphy's
defense bishop to a4 and knight to f6 we
have knight to c3 d6 d for now striking
in the center and now knight to d7 and
here you can already see uh the
difference between modern chess and uh
1896 chess where in modern chess b5
would be played right away uh whereas
knight the d7 isn't as impressive
because well it's
white can really take advantage of this
get some development in for example uh
if you go bishop to g5 you attack the
queen let's say bishop to e7 we're gonna
capture here
and now after queen captures we're going
to play knight to d5 and after the queen
moves because the c7 pawn is hanging
we're going to play d captures on e5 and
after knight captures we're going to
capture again so this knight is pinned
we're going to capture here now queen to
h5
and well it's already uh you can already
see that there's quite a lot of
development for for white here castles
and white is going to castle queen side
and this will be of course very very
good for white uh so that's why uh here
just a b5 instead of knight to d7 is
played nowadays but okay uh here uh
knight to d7 we have d5 uh by shalop uh
knight c the b8 by qigorin and bishop to
e3 so continuing development bishop to
e7 and now knights to e2 getting ready
to sorry knights to e2 getting ready to
push the c for pawn
we have castles by black and now knight
to g3 we have knight to f6 and now
finally c4
we have c5 you can see that black uh uh
did not play b5 at all uh for the moment
uh castles by white and knight b to d7
we have bishop back to c2 uh the pawn is
a little bit weak so maybe we want to
play knight to f5 we don't want to
weaken our e for pawn and now finally b5
uh we have b3 defending c4 rook to e8
and now knight to d2 they are getting
ready to uh to execute f4 here so here
knight to f8 remaneuvering the knight to
g6 we have h3 and now knight to g6 and
here
it's a very delicate position
that should be treated as a very modern
one for example with something like a4
and after black makes a little bit of d7
the the defend the b5 square maybe try
to overload that bishop with knight to
f5 uh so maybe white could uh
build build uh something on this but
here uh f4 was played because that's
what white prepared but this will be
very good for black as you'll see so
here black should capture on e4 why not
capture this bishop it's going to be
great rook captures we're going to play
knight to d7 bring the knight to e5 uh
and then maybe even bishop to f6 bishop
to d for 95
it should be very good for black
but after f4 we have the immediate
knight to d7 and now we have queen to h5
here black just allowed f5 and that's
not something you want to do you really
want to capture on f4 but okay this is
1896 chest so queen to h5 and now we
have e captures on f4 uh we have bishop
captures on f4 and now bishop to f6
still waiting with this capture on f4
first attacking the rook on a1 we have
rook 8 to d1 and now finally knight
captures on f4 we have rook captures on
f4 and the g6 now chasing the away the
white queen queen back to e2 and do not
bishop to e5
putting pressure on this uh rook here
rook back to f3 and now bishop to d4
with check we have king to h2 and now
knight to e5 so now black is playing uh
incredibly well these are the positions
that the old masters who really knew how
to handle uh and now you you can't
really save the rook the point is if you
go back let's say rook to f1 we're gonna
play knight to g for check that was
qigonian's idea and if h captures on g4
queen to h4 is checkmate the bishop
covers g1 so you couldn't really capture
the knight here you'd have to go back
the g1 square is covered by the bishop
not just knight e3 so you're gonna lose
the exchange regardless of what you play
so after knight e5 we have rook d to f1
and now bishop to g4 there's no russian
capturing material here we can just you
know repeat this again we know that the
g uh
anything that's in g4 cannot be captured
due to queen to h4 so queen to e1
unpinning and now qigoring just wins the
rook so bishop captures g captures and
now b captures on c4 uh some uh some
captures will occur now captures
captures captures and now rook to be a
tiger and of course wants to bring the
rook to b2 so shalom has to prevent this
he plays bishop to b3 but now a5 we will
gladly give up the pawn to open up the b
file to play rook to b2 so here knight
e2 attacking the bishop and chigami just
brings it back we have knight to c1
and now a4 of course we're going to give
up this pawn to open up the b file
bishop captures on a4 now comes rugby to
check kink the h1 and queen to c if not
you go in once the uh play queen
captures an h3 check so queen to g3 and
now rook to e5 we want to get the other
rook into the attack as well so queen g4
offering a queen trade uh and the now
queen to d8 avoiding the trade with
ideas of queen a5 maybe queen to d2
quint h2 checkmate it's not easy for
white to play this so queen to d7
uh now offering a queen trade and now
rook the g5 saying that okay if you
trade queens it's basically game over
for example captures capture so i'm
going to play
well if i play rook to g2 it's the game
over so you kind of have to play rook to
g1 and now i can just trade captures
captures and rogue rugby one and you're
gonna lose the knight and i'm just up
too much material so after look to g5 we
have knight to d3 attacking the rook
here uh but now uh the very nice queen
to a5 again offering material uh point
is if the rook is captured there's queen
to d2 and how are you stopping checkmate
again if rook g1 we can just capture
this if king captures bishop d4 check
and you're getting checkmated king to h1
queen e1 check you can go here queen to
g1 will be checkmate so instead after
queen to a5 we can't capture the rook
here we have to play rook to d1
but now it doesn't really matter we have
rook captures on a2 now threatening to
pick up the bishop bishop to b3 and now
rook back to d2
attacking the rook also if the rook
moves we're going to pick up the knight
and then now comes queen to a4
uh here charlotte offers a queen trade
but uh it's simply too late for such
things uh it's actually a forced mate in
nine for qigorin so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find this
beauty of a mate
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding any of the
nice moves like rook captures on d1 or
queen to c3 or or something like that
but none of this is mate in nine it's
mating more than nine but the mate in
nine is actually bishop to e5 we
sacrifice our queen and there's nothing
uh white can do about this or rather
white can't even accept the queen
because if you capture the queen it's
just a much quicker checkmate rook h2
and this is now checkmate so there
there's that of course the queen cannot
be captured so why is bishop to e5 so
strong well it doesn't matter what you
play if you block it with f4 we still
just capture and we're again threatening
mate in one so the bishop has to be
captured but now we simply play rook
captures on d1 check and we free this
diagonal to play queen to e1 so it
doesn't really matter if the rook is
captured let's say bishop captures queen
to e1 check king h2 and now queen the g2
will be checkmate and another one after
bishop to e5 let's say you decide to
just eliminate one of the attackers with
rook captures on d2 still queen captures
on d2 there's no defense this is
checkmate this is checkmate whatever you
play if queen to a2 guarding the second
rank uh we play queen captures on d3 now
threat and queen to f1 and if queen to
f2 not just queen b1 check and again
everything is checkmate queen to f1 uh
queen captures on f1 uh this is again
checkmate so after this queen a4 uh
qigori just played bishop to e5 and he
was in fact in this position on mu 41
that emil shalom resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
so yeah quite quite a game in this
tournament like i said we're gonna uh
probably cover it at some point so you
know i don't want to give up uh too much
from this tournament but of course you
guys are always wondering who won such a
prestigious event of course it was
emmanuel oscar uh who won it uh with a
with a full point lead and uh we well uh
it was just a wonderful tournament so
yeah we're gonna show uh at least one
more game uh that shalom played because
against weaker opponents he just creates
uh these beautiful masterpieces on the
board and you guys will will enjoy that
a lot
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and that you've enjoyed this
forced checkmate in nine moves that
starts with bishop to e5 hope a lot of
you uh were able to spot this uh i would
like to thank uh jonathan maesta uh
david hertz robert sterling benjamin
bryant and ryan urban for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day